Rachel's with us in San Diego hi Rachel
how are you hey I'm doing pretty good
I don't know how are you good so my
husband and I had a question I'm I'm at
home full-time with my two kids and I
from home I make about nine thousand a
year between watching my niece and
nephew and then ubering on the weekends
and then my husband takes him about
34,000 a year doing your financial piece
class we're in our last couple weeks of
the class we've got our emergency fund
set up the last set that we have is our
credit card debt it's about eight
thousand dollars in credit cards
so and we found a way to zero out the
zero out our budget our highest thing is
our car payments I thought you said the
last thing was your credit card debt so
you've got a car how much do you owe on
your car so it's a lease so we paid
about 431 a month for about 18 months
into it out of how many months three
years just about me we were about
halfway we are starting a savings to be
able to buy the car afterwards that car
that I am currently making payments on
is also the car that I use to make money
every weekend
[Music]
really yep we've been turning out the
budget we have our emergency funds we've
been saving I mean my house is a Steve
Ramsey we were wanting to expand our
family with one more child and he says
oh we need to be 100% out of debt and
like sitting perfectly before we have
more kids and I told well you know it's
our life we you know we can just plan
for I have all the cost IPERS because we
cross diaper
and I solve all the the babies stuffer
baby needs that we would need they knew
we were going to have more and I have
clothes sizes and here's the here's the
diagram she does not make baby decisions
yeah people make their own baby
decisions with God I don't make those
decisions and so you guys decided you
guys decided you guys decide I never
tell people that they should be
debt-free before they get married or
before they have children but you do
have to use some common sense correct
okay and that means you're probably
going to get rid of this car this car is
completely out of control a four hundred
and thirty one dollar payment in the
middle of all this is nightmarish and so
yeah I can help you with stuff like that
and and you know yeah he's probably
looking at some extra work himself
because you need you do need to clean up
this debt because raising three kids in
San Diego I don't care when we cloth
diapers you got raising three kids in
San Diego on fifty thousand dollars a
year which is about what you guys are
dealing with is tough that's tough and
you're sure not doing it with a dadgum
car payment coming out your ears so you
know it's not worth the who bore return
I would not finance a car to drive for
uber and effectively that's what you've
done here and I don't think what the
numbers are giving me you're going way
to buy this car at the end 18 months and
if you don't then for sure we know you
should have gotten rid of the car so if
you guys are willing to pick up a bunch
of extra work and clean up these last
two things the car problem and the
credit card debt problem it's going to
make it a whole lot easier to manage you
agree but but you know but no I don't I
don't make baby decisions God and God
and people make their own baby decisions
but you do have to you know you gotta
understand that this is hey going from
one to two is double going from three to
two three is thirty percent more I mean
thirty three percent more and so you go
from one on one defense to his own
defense when you go from two to three
and it changes the dynamic it changes a
lot of stuff but it's not untenable
people do it but you live in an
expensive city makes
to state and you guys don't make a lot
of money so we need to work on your
income side of the equation and you can
clean up the other stuff regardless of
when and and you have how you have kids
and so forth that's part of the equation
but no it's not it doesn't justify the
car by the fact that you drive it on the
weekends for Ober to keep a car you
can't afford it doesn't justify that at
all